Speaker 1: I don't know how many of you are
familiar with Liz Harrington. Liz Harrington
is Donald Trump's sort of Soviet style
spokeswoman. She, you know, North Korean
propaganda agents have seen Liz Harrington
and her videos and it makes them blush.
It's really something else. She is making the
unfounded claim. And this is sort of you know,
we've seen it evolve over time. First it was the
FBI planted the documents, then it was there were
no documents. Then it was they were there,
but they were Trump's right to have because
he declassified them. But the classification
didn't matter. So then it was back to, well,
the FBI plant. It's a circle, it's just a
revolving door. It's like a hamster wheel
of throwing a bunch of stuff at the wall to see
what sticks. Liz Harrington is now going back to
Biden and his administration have directed
this entire thing. Check out her interview
on the water cooler on Real America's Voice.
Speaker 2: How much do you think the Biden
administration is involved with this, specifically
Joe Biden? Then again, with Joe Biden,
we're never quite sure what he knows at this
point with all this because. But what's your
sense about the Biden administration? How much
do you think this is going to trail back to them?
Well, I mean, similarly to what happened
with the Russiagate. Right. I mean,
it's mostly the largely the.
Speaker 1: Russiagate.
Speaker 2: Same people that were involved in the
Obama-Biden administration and this setting up
the false accusations of Russia collusion with
the Clinton campaign. But that was all spun into
motion during the transition period using, you
know, this lawfare, but also the intelligence
community against their political opponent.
So I think they're very much involved. I think
it's very much the same people and that's what
we really need. I think to your point, David,
the answers to we need accountability here.
Speaker 1: And so she says it's obvious that
Biden was very, very involved and also throwing in
during another moment of the interview, Trump can
have whatever the hell he wants at his house.
Speaker 2: The big question still does remain
about why President Trump had these records
there down at Mar a Lago in the first place.
Is there anything you can tell us about
that? I think that's kind of one thing
that's still been out there. People trying to
understand that, yeah, the person is trying to.
Speaker 1: Because it's completely
not understandable unless it's for
nefarious regional reasons or unless Trump
wants to pretend to still be president.
Speaker 2: And that. I think the key point was
that presidential records act presidential is
the president and the fake news media is trying to
pretend that he wasn't or that he was just some,
you know, paper pusher like these bureaucrats at
the National Archives know he's the president is
correspondent. He had every right to keep whatever
he wants and possess whatever he wanted to. And
obviously, when he left the White House, he took
some documents with him. That was his prerogative.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that not only is
that not true, it doesn't actually answer the
question. The question was, why did Trump want
the documents? And there really is no benign
explanation. It's the explanations go from bad to
very, very bad to really, really bad, like treason
is bad. And her answer is both not an answer
to the question, but it's also not true that he
can just take whatever he wants, even Republican
strategist Karl Rove said on Fox News the other
night. These are simply not Trump's documents to
take. You don't just declassify things by saying,
I wish them declassified and things are not
de facto declassified because Trump, you know,
stuck them in his pants or in a box and took
them to his house. So really just Soviet style
propaganda there from Liz Harrington. And we have
to hope. Here's the hope. Okay. I've said before,
I think Trump's getting indicted. I don't think
he's going to prison. There has been a lot of
really bad stuff that went on here, and it seems
clear that at least some people committed crimes.
If no one ends up seeing consequences for what
has gone on, it will be a major indictment of
the two tiered American justice system. Not
that we need more indictments of it. It's
been indicted plenty. We've seen that over the
last decade. But it would be a real injustice
if there are no consequences for what went down.
And all we can do is continue to wait and see.